[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
philosophie einer sendung des
kulturprogramms des schweizer fernsehens
offenbar interessieren sie sich auch für
kultur
doch warum eigentlich kultur war seit
krone aufzuhören sei nicht
systemrelevant
was aber ist die dann der bundesrat hat
am mittwoch entschieden veranstaltungen
bis zu 300 personen ab dem 6 juni
zuzulassen veranstaltungen mit über 1000
personen bleiben bis ende august
verboten
bringt das nun die erhoffte rettung oder
bricht ist der kulturbranche erst recht
das genick und was verlieren wir wenn
kultur lokale sterben
darüber diskutieren wir etwas später in
der sendung mit der philosophin
christine abt und dem co intendanten des
zürcher schauspielhauses nicolas stemann
jetzt zuerst ist mir aber dirk becker
zugeschaltet er ist soziologe und
professor für kulturtheorie und
management in witten herdecke herzlich
willkommen herr becker und otto becker
sie haben vor 20 jahren dieses buch
geschrieben so zu kultur eine reine ist
es her aber irgendwie denkt man bei
diesem titel kultur ist
rechtfertigungsbedarf tick ja das buch
ist auch ein versuch die kultur zu
rechtfertigen vor allem ein versuch die
beschäftigung der wissenschaft mit der
kultur zu rechtfertigen
man hat ja immer sein wissen das gefühl
dass kultur das sahnehäubchen auf der
gesellschaft ist und dass wir eigentlich
wichtigen dinge im beruf in der freien
leben der familie in der freizeit sich
abspielen und kultur gleich nur die
entspannung ist die man sich am abend
könnt aber mein eindruck war das geht
schwer an der sache vorbei
ich würde am liebsten mit mit sigmund
freud dem psychiater argumentieren und
sagen unser leben in dieser gesellschaft
des kulturell so anspruchsvoll
wir müssen uns so sehr zusammenreißen an
vielen punkten band ihren beruf in der
familie beim einkaufen unterwegs sind
dass wir abends eine form der
auseinandersetzung dieser spannung
brauchen das was wir kultur nennen also
die beschäftigung mit kunst es
eigentlich so etwas für die abfuhr der
täglichen spannung zu gunsten des
begreifens nicht nur zugunsten der
unterhaltung sondern das
einfluss dieser spannungen und deswegen
ist der theaterbesuch der konzertbesuch
auch dass der kinobesuch eine absolut
unverzichtbare angelegenheit haben sie
gesprochen vom sahnehäubchen zugleich
auch von der vielleicht
entspannungstechnik die kultur sein kann
wenn man fragt wozu kultur wollen die
natürlich immer auch gleich wissen was
ist denn eigentlich kultur und die
schreiben in diesem buch zu fragen was
ist kultur da kommt sofort der
stoßseufzer weil man nämlich denken gott
sagen das kann man ja überhaupt gar
nicht definieren
versuchen wir es trotzdem was ist kultur
also es gibt tatsächlich versuche kultur
zu definieren ein großartiges buch von
amerikanischen wissenschaftlern die
kommen auch sage und schreibe 150
definitionen wie will ich jetzt nicht
alle froh erzählt mir reicht eine
einzige mir reicht eine einzige
definition nämlich die unterscheidung
der antiken kultur von der modernen
kultur die antike kultur das haben wir
immer noch in begriffen wie agrikultur
oder auch cicero war jemand der sagte
die philosophie seine kultur anime ein
kultivierter umgang mit der eigenen
seele die antike kultur war eine kultur
der pflege der verehrung und vor allem
auch des wissens um das unverfügbare
also agrikultur das bestellen von äckern
ist ja nichts anderes als die
auseinandersetzung damit dass man sehen
kann und dass man auch dafür sorgen kann
dass sich allzu viele vögel das sagt
aufblicken aber dann wachsen muss es von
alleine kultur ist die
auseinandersetzung mit etwas was
umsorgten werden muss aber dann von
alleine wächst an außer nicht spannender
begriff den wir heute in der ökologie
auch wieder gut verwenden können moderne
kultur ist etwas ganz anderes die
moderne kultur im 18 jahrhundert
entstanden bei rousseau bei hertha ist
eine kunst des vergleiches dann kam
irgendwann darauf dass franzose sich von
italiener italiener von schwaben und
alemannen von sensoren unterscheiden und
fragte sich woran das eigentlich liegt
und kam darauf zu sagen es liegt an
deren kultur an der art und weise wie
menschen miteinander umgehen welche
sitten welche bräuche sie pflegen wollen
sie glauben mit welchen besteck sie
essen ob sie bier oder wein trinkt und
ob sie kaffee oder tee trinken
eine eine große ein großes
intellektuelle spiel des vergleiches mit
den anderen mit desaströsen effekten das
muss man hinzufügen weil im 19
jahrhundert dann die große frage
auftauchte ja wer sind wir denn wenn wir
uns nur in der kultur von anderen
unterscheiden und die desaströse also
die wirklich katastrophen produzierende
antwort war wir sind wir weil wir wir
sind seither ist dieses große stichwort
der identität der des versuchs der
unvergleichbarkeit im spiel und wir
verlieren all das was der witz der
modernen kultur im achtzehnten
jahrhundert und was das wissen der
kultur in der antike war ein gut aus den
augen ich finde das unglaublich
interessant also kultur sozusagen aus
einer form von vergleichsverfahren wir
fahren da auch gleich ganz viele
beispiele einige vergleichen die
asiatische kultur mit der westlichen
kultur wir vergleichen hochkultur mit
popkultur wie vergleichen sogar den
kulturbanausen mit dem kultivierten
menschen also es ist eigentlich dauernd
eine form von ausgrenzung eingrenzung
abhärtung auswertung wenn wir über
kultur sprechen
haben sie das ganz interessantes gesagt
sie haben gesagt es geht auch um den
begriff der identität und das ist ja
wirklich eigentlich sowie eine
ambivalenz in diesen begriff also
einerseits wollen sie mit der kultur
ausgrenzen und eingrenzen
andererseits geht es auch darum
gemeinschaften zu bilden oder
gemeinschaften zu stärken
via kultur ja der haken an dieser form
von identität ist dass sie eine
auseinandersetzung mit dem anderen
voraussetzt
wenn ich nicht von anderen abgrenzen
muss um zu wissen wer ich bin
dann ist die diese auseinandersetzung
mit dem anderen bereits teil meiner
eigenen identität
ich komme also gar nicht mehr dazu
rundum und ganz rein und ganz sauber
kulturtheorie soft eine theorie ist rein
und des sauberen in der beschreibung
älterer kulturen ich komme gar nicht
dazu rein und sauber zu sein weil ich
bereits das ergebnis einer differenz
eine diskussion eine unterscheidung von
anderen bin so dass man eigentlich wenn
man
ein kultureller unter den arbeiten
möchte nur empfehlen kann dass das nicht
allzu intensiv zu tun wenn man danach
eine paradoxie stößt man ist das worin
man sich von anderen unterscheidet und
ob das beunruhigt oder beruhigt es hat
eine zweite frage eine andere solche
vergleichsgröße ist diejenige der natur
also manchmal vergleichen wir ja auch
kultur und natur und in der
philosophiegeschichte war es ja auch so
eine bewegung die immer wieder engagiert
harz zwischen einer vereinnahmung der
kultur und einer abstoßung also denken
die daran beispielsweise bei uns so ist
die kultur eigentlich das große drama
der mensch wäre frei geboren aber er
liegt in ketten unter anderem wegen der
kultur war der mensch versucht besser zu
sein als die natur sich über die natur
zu erheben
zugleich gibt es natürlich bei china zum
beispiel die vorstellung der kultivierte
mensch ist eben der zivilisierte mensch
ist derjenige der mehr aus sich macht
das was die natur wäre ja eine extrem
spannende entwicklung die das ganze 16
17 18 jahrhundert eigentlich beginnt
berufen dorf den großen latour ex lehrer
begonnen hat die einen sagen kultur
macht uns glücklich weil wir nicht
gezwungen sind wie die tiere unter
natürlichen bedingungen zu leben und den
bedingungen der not der notwendigkeit
und die anderen großen sagen und kultur
macht uns unglücklich weil wir nicht
mehr so leben dürfen so frei und
ungebunden in den tag hinein die bananen
von den brücken wie die tiere
der spannende punkt daran ist jetzt für
mich aus einer kultur theoretischen
sicht nicht etwa die frage haben die
einen oder die anderen rechten es
tatsächlich glücklich oder unglücklich
sondern die spannende frage ist es ist
immer beides möglich
in dem moment in dem ich über kultur
nachdenken kann ich dinge beschreiben
zum beispiel die kultur weil ich sag
jetzt mal der monogamen ehe ja die mich
zwingt so zu leben wie ich lebe und ich
kann andere dinge beschreiben die kultur
der polyamorie also der vielseitigkeit
die mich möglicherweise glücklich machen
und dasselbe kann ich auch umgekehrt
sein
ich kann es bleiben nur die monogamie
quartal macht nicht glücklich und die
polyamorie wo
nie genau weiß woran ich bin macht mich
unglücklich das heißt die frage der
kultur ist selbst die entdeckung dass
ich es bin ich der beobachter der werten
darf was nicht glücklich oder
unglücklich machen ich habe da eine
eigene entscheidung die ich selber
treffen muss das heißt auch der
kulturtheoretiker bleibt neutral sie
würden auch sagen auch die mafia hat
eine kultur wir müssen da nicht eine
ethische dimension mit rein nehmen und
sagen das ist dann eine unkultur oder
keine kultur und kultur ist selbst auch
eine kultur
wir haben ja in der zumindest in den
kulturwissenschaften diese begriffe wie
hoch kultur und subkultur hinter uns
gelassen und sprechen nur von den kultur
rennen im plural und da ist die kultur
des verbrechers genauso wertvoll wie die
kultur des fernsehzuschauers ja das war
das war ja kalt studies in birmingham in
16 17 jahren das waren ja leute die
gesagt haben wir dürfen nicht nur nach
oxford und cambridge schauen wenn wir
nach kultur uns umschauen wir müssen
auch den fernsehzuschauer poser der
glotze als jemanden betrachten der sich
kultiviert das mag dann manch nicht
gefallen was da passiert aber wenn wir
diese sendung hier zum beispiel denken
das ist derjenige der uns zuschaut
sicherlich als ein kultivierter als ein
reflektierter was jemand der seine
eigene kultur definiert durch das fast
food lokal ich bewusst es gibt keinen
grund irgendetwas abzuwerten es sei denn
man bezieht die position einer anderen
kultur die sich dann bestimmt als eine
die glaubt andere abwerten zu können ich
musste in dieser ganzen corona zeit
interessanterweise immer wieder an eine
textzeile denken aus einem lied von
element of crime der berliner bands da
gibt es eine wunderbare liedzeile die
heißt ohne klarheit in der sprache ist
der mensch nur ein gartenzwerg und ich
habe einen gartenzwerg mitgenommen
ich glaube diese zeile ist mir so lief
weil ich tatsächlich glaube dass sich
für mich so ein bisschen für ein
kulturverständnis steht also vielleicht
nicht nur ohne klarheit in der sprache
sondern ohne reflexion raum ohne kultur
ist der mensch nur ein gartenzwerg für
mich würde das irgendwie eine definition
sein der ich zustimmen könnte weil der
gartenzwerg der ist eine verzehr
dessen was wir sein könnten der
gartenzwerg steht einfach nur im garten
rum
er habe nicht die möglichkeit sich zu
beziehen auf seine umwelt können sie mit
der definition was anfangen verzwergung
des ichs ist der mensch ohne gut ja ich
finde das eine sehr schöne definition
das ist der der mensch als automat der
mensch dem jede spontanität zählt der
mensch der sich von anderen hinstellen
lassen und dann angucken muss und
natürlich auch belächeln lassen muss das
ist sicherlich nicht vorstellen wie wir
von einem kultivierten referierten
menschen haben habe ich würde das bild
vielleicht auch ganz gerne umdrehen und
wird danach den fragen die gartenzwerg
in ihre gärten stellen sind das sind das
ihrerseits verstärkte menschen auf die
idee käme nicht glaube ich habe schon
das gefühl naja ein bisschen spießig ist
es ein gartenzwerg in den garten zu
stellen
aber eigentlich ist das ja ausweist
dessen was den menschen am kultivierten
nach nämlich ein gewisser sinn für
rick's ein gewisser sinn für eine
verzwergung der mann sich fallweise
durchaus unterwirft stecke jetzt an den
moment in dem wir uns selbst in den
garten setzen unser lieblingsbier öffnen
und einen moment nichts anderes tun als
lustig in die in die bäume zu schauen
dann schauen wir uns an einen
gartenzwerg an und denkt na ja so ganz
reduzieren dass ich mich auf die
verzwergung nicht ich bin doch derjenige
der sich von meinem gartenzwerg also von
mir selbst sozusagen unterscheidet und
dann hat man sofort die eigentlich
spannende frage was mache ich denn bin
ich spontan bin was mache ich denn wenn
ich meine freiheit meine
bewegungsspielräume in anspruch nehmen
was mache ich denn wenn ich aus dem
zwergen dasein auszubrechen versuchen
dann stellen sich die eigentlich
spannenden fragen das spüre ich auch den
soziologen in ihnen also nicht nur zu
fragen was ist kultur sondern immer zu
fragen was ist denn der zweck dessen was
wir da gerade machen oder der zweck des
gartens werks wenn der gartenzwerg
führen wird steht für den humor steht
wird der zu kultur könnte man auch sagen
vielleicht ein offener kann sich nur die
banane klauen vom baum wir kleben
bananen auch an wände und sagen das ist
kunst
aber dann ist es ein ein kultureller
andreasried sein kollege von ihnen hat
gesagt kultur ist vielleicht nicht
systemrelevant aber sie ist humor
relevant vielleicht gerade weil sie
zeigt wer wir als menschen sind was ich
mich frage zur der mensch ist
seinerseits systemrelevant also dass
roman relevant ist ja dass
systemrelevante schlecht hinten
anstellen man zählt es die gegenwärtige
corona gesellschaft vor der ja extrem
viele menschliche leistungen
wirtschaftliche politische aber eben
auch kulturelle zurückgefahren werden
und in dem man kürzlich entdeckt dass
dieser gesellschaft das entscheidende
nämlich die bewegungsfreiheit der
menschen fehlt wie alle haben das
akzeptiert weil wir wissen die epidemie
lässt uns keine andere wahl
aber man stelle sich auf dauer eine
solche gesellschaft vor und man entdeckt
dass der mensch dass systemrelevante
schlecht themen ist der mensch im
singular und die menschen in blu ray und
das ist die kultur und das ist eine
theorie die mich am meisten fasziniert
bei all dem was ich da jahrelang dazu
gelesen und geschrieben habe dass die
kultur eigentlich ein dauernder versuch
ist eine gewisse balance meiner
menschlichen zustände also dessen was
ich denke was ich fühle was ich empfinde
was ich erhoffe und was ich fürchte mit
der jeweiligen gesellschaftlichen
umgebung also das was wir geboten wird
das was von mir erwartet wird das was
wir zugemutet wird in der balance zu
bringen
der gartenzwerg ist ja auch nichts
anderes als eine momentane balance
zwischen dem der der verzweigung die ich
mit meinem eigenen garten leiste und dem
wissen um die ansprüche an komplexität
die mir mein beruf in meiner familie
meiner freizeit begegnen
kultur ist wenn man tatsächlich so
ontologisch formulieren will kultur ist
eigentlich eine balance mechanismus
zwischen meinem gemüt meiner
sinnlichkeit auf der einen seite und
meinem wunsch aber eben auch zwang mich
in der gesellschaft zu und einigermaßen
zu verstehen was dort passiert und jetzt
haben wir einen großen bogen geschlagen
von der kultur als sahnehäubchen bis hin
zu eigentlich unserer science weise in
der welt da sehen wir ja auch wie breit
der kulturbegriff eigentlich ist wenn
wir jetzt auch noch einmal mehr zum
sahnehäubchen charakter der kultur
zurückkommen würde sie gerne fragen als
kulturtheoretiker wenn nun
kulturbetriebe unter druck geraten wenn
es zu einem sterben von kulturbetrieben
kommt die torischen
draußen bleiben oder nur mit
schutzkonzepte zögerlich wieder öffnen
können was verlieren die aus
gesellschaft wir verlieren entscheidende
momente der reflektion auf unserer
eigenen zustände
wenn jemand ins theater geht ich mache
das sehr häufig so häufig wie möglich
muss schon versagen wenn man ins theater
geht dann schaut man den eigenen
menschlichen situationen dabei zu wie
sie sich entwickeln wie sie in bestimmte
konflikte hineinschlittern wie sie
kommunikative aspekte entwickeln wie sie
daraus wieder ins tragische kippen
es gibt nirgendwo anders als im theater
eigentlich die möglichkeit gesellschaft
zu studieren auch der bühne dem
zuzuschauen das man normalerweise im
leben so gott sei dank nicht erlebt aber
möglicherweise doch erlebt wenn wir wenn
wir ins konzert gehen haben wir eine
einzigartige möglichkeit popkonzert und
jazz konzert genauso wie im klassischen
konzert den unruhezuständen unseres
eigenen bewusstseins auf die spur zu
kommen indem man seinem eigenen gehört
sozusagen anhören kann welche harmonien
gefallen mir welche disharmonien brauche
ich welche nervosität in welcher art von
musik ist das was mir am ehesten in
meiner gegenwärtigen lebens anspannung
entgegen kommt welche art von ich sage
mal mit mozart welche art von beruhigung
zum zum glück zur gelungenen auflösung
eines akkord brauche ich um doch son so
etwas wie das gute in der gesellschaft
oder in menschen oder in der welt zu
bleiben
die kultur von der wir hier reden und
von der eben manche behaupten dieser das
sahnehäubchen
diese kultur ist eigentlich die
wichtigste form des nachdenkens über uns
selber des beobachtens von uns selber
und deswegen auch des gewinns von
freiheit im umgang mit sich selber die
wir kennen
sie haben vorhin gesagt es gibt für sie
nicht hochkultur und popkultur sondern
kulturen
dennoch haben sie jetzt kulturen erwähnt
die natürlich mehr dem zu gehören was
ich als hochkultur bezeichnen theater
mozart haben sie genannt
wenn jetzt diese institution schließen
würden und alle gucken einfach
stattdessen netflix
dann ist das ja auch eine kultur
verlieren wir dennoch etwas das ich das
wichtig dass bestimmte kulturen
überleben
nein das ist es nicht
ich bin der festen auffassung dass das
was wir im theater im konzert oder
sonstwo erleben gleich sagen im moment
unseres board wieder neu kreiert werden
kann ich gucke gegenwärtig aus dem
fenster heraus in einem großen park
hinein in dresden und ich sehe dort fast
täglich leute die übungen machen die
anderen mit ihrer gitarren musik
erfreuen die texte lesen wir werden nie
im leben darauf verzichten können
reflektion form unserer eigenen existenz
wie spontan oder wie wie dilettantisch
auch immer die welt zu setzen und wir
können gleichsam so ähnlich wie auch
wirtschaft sich in dem moment wieder neu
starten lässt wird irgendjemand sagt er
weil ich hätte gern das was du da hast
was willst du von mir haben wir können
damit rechnen dass auch ohne die großen
institutionen auch ohne den riesigen
apparat an kulturfinanzierung kultur
wider und kunst vor allem wieder
gestartet werden könnte wenn sie denn
was sich kein mensch wünscht
an ein ende kommen wird als an das
ändern das segel schon gedacht hat und
das nicht eingetreten ist
ich will nur einfach zu sagen ich
wünsche uns nicht ein gesellschaft den
zustand in dem dieses ausprobiert wird
was wir gegenwärtig an institutionen im
künstlerischen bereich entwickelt haben
ist so hochwertig und ist so kraftvoll
in der unterstützung von so vielen
leuten die sich nicht die nichts anderes
tun von worms haben zwischen von morgens
früh bis abends spät als über
künstlerische angebote diese
gesellschaft nachzudenken dass wir uns
ein ersparen dieser leistung behaftet
nicht leisten sollten herr becker ich
danke ihnen sehr ich möchte gerne
schließen mit diesem lob auf das
kulturschaffen vielen herzlichen dank
für dieses gespräch
becker ich sagte ihm druck los ja das
theater sprechen dir gleich weiter viele
häuser mussten sich etwas einfallen
lassen nachdem man ihnen verboten hat
ihre stücke noch vor publikum
aufzuführen
nicola stemer und co intendant des
zürcher schauspielhauses hat sich
gefragt was in früheren solchen zeiten
gemacht wurde
und kam aufs passionsspiel mittlerweile
sind zehn folgen seiner passionsspiele
im netz aufgeschaltet kurze musikalische
video produktionen in denen das
zeitgeschehen humorvoll reflektiert wird
schauen wir einen ausschnitt aus der
neuesten folge in denen zwei
schauspieler auf der leeren bühne
beklagen dass man sie doch längst
vergessen habe
[Musik]
apa
[Applaus]
fr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja bei mir sitzen jetzt nicolas stemann
intendant des schauspielhauses zürich
und christina professorin für
philosophie an der universität graz
herzlich willkommen
und ja fragt wir haben einen ausschnitt
jetzt gesehen aus diesen corona
passionsspielen passionsspiele die haben
normalerweise das leiden jesu am
karfreitag thematisiert wie ist es für
sie sie sehen hier jetzt leidende
schauspieler leidende künstler leiden
sieht auch mit ja ich denke schon also
ich leide mit ja und wie man sieht auch
so schön wie die beiden auf der bühne ja
alles haben tolles haus körperausdruck
musik tanz alles ist da nur es fehlt das
publikum und ohne publikum funktioniert
theater nicht und ja das tut weh man
habe der bundesrat ja entschieden am
mittwoch dass ab dem 6 juni wieder
vorstellungen stattfinden dürfen mit 300
personen also publikum darf wieder rein
allerdings nicht alles reicht ihnen das
das ist auf jeden fall erstmal mehr als
nichts und das ist auch mehr als wir
erwartet hatten tatsächlich also das
erst mal eine positive überraschung
wir selber haben aber das kommt ja auch
in diesem video zum ausdruck dass
natürlich auch ironisch überhöht ist und
so weiter aber die sehnsucht danach
wieder spielen zu dürfen
wir haben gesagt wir werden auf jeden
fall im juni wider spiegeln das heißt
wir hätten auch spielen können unter den
gegebenen bedingungen und haben uns
formate überlegte gehen zum beispiel zu
den bedingungen unter denen auch ein
museum wieder öffnen da wurde ein
restaurant wieder öffnen darf oder man
auch tram fahren darf und haben deswegen
wirklich einen schönen juni spielplan
und dass der bundesrat wird sagt es
dürfen da sogar bis zu 300 leute rein
macht es uns erstmal viel einfacher
diesen diesem spiel kann umgesetzt aber
es sind sehr besondere format also wir
fahren jetzt nicht von heute auf morgen
unser ganzes repertoire wieder hoch wäre
auch wenig sinnvoll jetzt die wenigen
wochen vorm sommer aber anders als viele
andere theater und europa häuser die
gesagt haben wir spielen gar nicht mehr
bis zum sommer machen wir immer gesagt
wir arbeiten darauf hin dass sobald es
die kleinste lücke gibt wieder vor
menschen in unseren räumen spielen zu
können dass wir diese gelegenheit
ergreifen und das können wir jetzt durch
nun hat peer teuwsen in der nzz am
sonntag
einer woche sie angegriffen er hat
gesagt opernhäuser schauspielhäuser
hätten radikal verfolgt in dieser krise
er hätte für an den anarchischen geist
der kulturschaffenden vermisst was
entgegnen sie ja schön also mir darauf
ansprechen weil das ist also der titel
strotzt vor unwahrheiten und schlecht
recherchierten fakten was pärchen am
anfang macht es zu sagen alles was
online passiert gilt nicht und darüber
entgeht ihm dass wir ein umfangreiches
online programm gestaltet haben und zwar
auch wiederum weitergehend als viele
andere institutionen also am anfang
haben alle gesagt okay wir haben noch
ein paar mitschnitte die stellen wir ins
netz und streamen alte aufnahmen da
haben wir am anfang von vornherein
gesagt das werden wir nicht tun das ist
uns zu wenig genuin theatralisch wir
suchen nach von morton von formaten die
auch online funktionieren aber die was
mit theater zu tun haben
dadurch sind zum beispiel diese corona
passionsspiele das ist so ein
begleitendes work in progress das ist im
grunde eine vorbereitung für etwas was
wir im juni dann auf einer bühne zeigen
werden endlich uni im schiffbau
wenn wir in der halle und auch im foyer
und im atrium haben wir einen garten
gepflanzt in der korona zeit dort wird
das stattfinden lassen sie uns
vielleicht noch kurz bei diesem
anarchischen geist bleiben weil sie frau
ab haben in einem nwz artikel ja gesagt
theater und demokratie das hängt ganz
eng zusammen oder man kann sehr viel
lernen über demokratie wenn man auch
über theater spricht anarchischer geist
dem tierhalter was glauben sie haben
herr theisen vermisst dann weiß ich
nicht was er isst hat aber wenn man
jetzt über den zusammenhang von
demokratie und her auch danach denkt der
lohnt sich natürlich schon ein blick
noch mal zurück als im fünften
jahrhundert eben diese demokratie also
eine total neue ordnung ein total neues
selbstverständnis groß geworden ist ist
gleichzeitig auch das der ort zu einer
unglaublichen blüte kommen und das
theater war in dieser zeit wirklich ein
politischer resonanzraum also einem
grinsen anzahlung für das sozial und das
politische und das war weitgehend
unzensuriert und frei und es ist
interessant dass zum beispiel dann in
athen als die demokraten jahr an der
macht waren eben im theater von
aristophanes häufig die demokraten
veräppelt werden also verlacht
verspottet das sind die lächerlichen
figuren und das war alles möglich und
ich glaube wenn theater eben diesen
resonanzraum des sozialen und und des
politischen auch bleibt und und bleiben
kann
in freien gesellschaften dann ja dann
hat demokratie und theater sehr viel
miteinander und voneinander zu tun da
ist interessant weil das ist natürlich
was wo wir jetzt in grad in der letzten
saison wo wir angefangen haben ganz
ausdrücklich daran arbeiten also wie
kriegt man eigentlich die policy sich da
versammelt in diesem theater erweitert
man hört jetzt yamagata ist ein
lebensmittel wir brauchen das wir
brauchen kultur und so steht auch ein
bisschen über dieser sendung wo ich mich
immer frage was ist denn genau damit
gemeint also ist man nicht auch
irgendwie teilnehmen in einem
demokratischen gemeinwesen wenn man sich
jetzt nicht für klassische musik oder
klassische stücke interessiert wie
kriegt man das erweitert wie kriegt man
das publikum erweitert wie kriegt man
das weg davon dass es jetzt irgendwie so
ein engagement für die besser gestellten
schichten ist und das ist wirklich zu
diesem auftrag zurück kommt da sind wir
sehr dran also wir haben sprechen sehr
unterschiedliche publikumsschichten an
wenn meine auch sehr sehr
unterschiedliche kunstformen also wir
haben leute die mit der bildenden kunst
zu tun haben wir wohl sengenthal kommt
ans wir haben sehr junge regisseurinnen
und regisseure die ganz eigene
theatersprache irgendwie entwickelt und
darüber merkt man das publikum verändert
sich und trotzdem dass unser anspruch
das altehrwürdige publikum bleibt das
ist und so hoffen wir wollen keine leute
verletzen
und jetzt ist eine situation wo eine
gefährliche pandemie ausbricht und es
bestimmte sicherheitsvorkehrungen und
vorschriften gibt die besagen dass wir
nicht mehr spielen dürfen
und die besagen dass versammlungen von
mehr als fünf menschen in außenräumen
verboten sind und jetzt kann man
natürlich in der mz redaktionsstube
sitzen und am letzten sonntag schreiben
warum habt ihr diese regel nicht
gebrochen ihr seid doch anarchisten wo
ich dann zurück man kann ja fleißig nzz
wird auch auf home office umgestellt
haben und ich hab nichts gegen
künstlerische regelbrüche dass ich habe
ein t shirt mit harald nägeli es motiv
drauf also ich mag das eigentlich gerne
regeln in frage zu stellen und damit
auch zum spiel
ob das sinnvoll ist das kommt auch die
regeln darauf an
und in diesem fall ist es nicht so klar
die regeln so sinnlos sind und wir
tragen eine verantwortung wir haben
einen betrieb mit über 350
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern eine
verantwortung für unsere zuschauerinnen
für die gesundheit der gesellschaft
nicht mehr diese kritik sprechen gleich
zurück noch heimat zur politischen
sprengkraft auf das theater das theater
eigentlich vermag sie haben vorhin
gesagt für die politische
meinungsbildung war früher das theater
auch wichtig also die menschen durften
ja zum beispiel der griechischen polis
nicht einfach teilnehmen auf dem forum
da wo die politischen regeln gemacht
wurden sie durften aber alle ins theater
gehen und davon eigentlich der diskurs
statt
ja das waren sich eine riesen
angelegenheit also im idealen sparen
viel mehr leute zugelassen als jetzt im
forum und das ging über tage komödien
und dann auch tragödien und was aber
schon interessant ist dass auch schon in
der antike bemerkt wurde das eben wenn
man einen ganzen tag im theater sitzt
dass das einerseits wichtig ist aber
andererseits dass dann der der lohn die
die arbeit die man machen muss liegen
bleibt und es wurde dann also auch
geschlossen zu einer gewissen zeit dass
man eben lohnersatz zahlt damit man ins
theater kann und damit man diese vielen
tage da verbringt kann aber ja die
politische sprengkraft gleich noch einen
kommentar zum anarchischen nicht mehr
die politische sprengkraft kann
natürlich auch nicht daran liegen
wiederum solche erwartungen als auch
nach china zu erfüllen dann ist man
wieder die gleise und das ist es gerade
nicht oder sie ist eben ein freiraum der
ausprobiert der vielleicht manchmal auch
konventionell ist ist auch noch kunst
und kultur irgendwas begriffe auch
nochmals schaffen und theater die
sprengkraft ist ja auch das scheint mir
immer so besonders deutlich wenn man die
gegner von offenen gesellschaften an
schaut also können wir wieder anfang
hatte er nur schon beim rollenspiel also
bei der imitation einfach eine
ungeheurer sprengkraft sieht und zwar
eine freiheitliche und wiederum hobbs
nimmt das auch auf thomas hobbes im
livia tann und ist eine besondere stelle
wo eben den untertanen in diesen
absolutistischen vielleicht anfänglich
demokratisch vertraglichen aber dann
auch im absolutistischen staat eben
verboten
ist nicht nur allein in einem dunklen
zimmer darf jemand in könig imitieren
was das entscheidende ist dass jemand
spüren könnte das zwischen sich und dem
könig gar nicht so eine eindeutige
trennung besteht und dass man selber
vielleicht auch könig sein könnte also
das ist da irgendwie eine chance ihren
gibt also imitation zum beispiel
rollenspiele vorführen das alles eben
auch anders sein könnte und dass wir
andere sagt finden das hat eine enorme
ist ja auch so die die alte rolle des
hofnarren sozusagen der auch so eine
figur ist wichtig für eine gesellschaft
mich wird aber trotzdem noch
interessieren wenn wir dabei bleiben kam
das theater das eigentlich heute noch
passiert ja oft gefordert theater oder
kultur kunst soll politisch sein
mich interessiert diese frage gar nicht
so sehr sie dass sie das nicht
sonderlich interessiert die frage kommen
sie das heute eigentlich noch sein weil
wir zum beispiel schon nur zurückgehen
in die ddr
dann hat man gemerkt in der ddr wurden
natürlich theater gefährlich für das
regime weil da sachen ausprobiert wurden
sachen korrigiert wurden sachen
thematisiert wurden die unter ben becker
gehalten wurden heute frage ich mich
kann eigentlich theater noch gefährlich
werden
das kommt das besondere an was sie unter
gefährlich verständigt wenn wir nicht
froh jetzt über diese beispiele die ich
nicht kannte von hopps also das spiel
also das spielerische und dass es
vielleicht anders jetzt als in
diktaturen wo es wirklich darum geht
subversiv dinge zu platzieren die man im
öffentlichen diskurs nicht sagen kann
im moment gibt es auch andere meinungen
zu aber meine meinung ist das nicht dass
man doch eine ganze menge sagen da sind
unsere gesellschaft wird auch offen
und dass er so ein bisschen im moment
das problem ist auf welche art diskurse
geführt werden und wie schnell die sich
eigentlich verhärten das hängt auch mit
den medien zusammen mit social media und
so weiter also es gibt vertiefen sich
enorm schnell gräben
man will immer nur bestätigt werden in
einer meinung die man vermeintlich hat
wo man aber auch gar nicht ganz genau
weiß wo kommt sie her auf welchen fakten
basiert die usw
und da erleben wir im moment mit ganz
eine verdummung des diskurses eine
verhärtung des diskurses und
militarisierung des diskurses
oder ein militant werden des diskurses
und da glaube ich finde dass derart eine
funktion und das hängt mit dem spiel
zusammen
das hängt mit dem ehren mit dem spiel
zusammen hängt auch mit dem narrativ
zusammen und mit der möglichkeit geht
auch auf die griechische tragödie zurück
zusammen sich in seinem spielerischen
rahmen konflikt immer von außen zugucken
sondern sagt wir haben ein konflikt der
ist also die meinetwegen zwischen natur
und kultur oder zwischen staat und und
familiärem anspruch oder so wie bei
antigone und wir wollen jetzt nicht in
diesem konflikt verharren und verhärten
sondern wir treten um ein schritt zurück
und gucken uns den stellvertretend
vorgespielt von zwei menschen an oder
zwei darstellern und haben dadurch die
möglichkeit noch eine andere position
einzunehmen und vielleicht auch die
gegenseite zu verstehen und darüber
spielerisch diskurse in bewegung zu
bringen
doch das brauchen wir das kraft brauchen
die ich meine wie wäre nicht
philosophien und philosophischen wenn
wir nicht genau das wollen würden mit
diskursen themen setzen verändern zum
denken anregen
trotzdem werde ich noch mal gerne fragen
zum beispiel ihre inszenierung von atlas
trakt von renz eine philosophin die von
der konservativen libertären tea party
in den usa eigentlich vereinnahmt worden
ist
sie haben dieses stück aufgenommen es
wurde sehr viel darüber diskutiert um im
grunde genommen der wirtschafts elite
des finanzplatzes ans bein zu pinkeln
wenn man so will oder zu thematisieren
was passiert wenn die wirtschafts elite
sich als opfer stilisiert darüber würde
ich wurde gesprochen es wurde breit
diskutiert aber die frage wäre ja
politische sprengkraft kann man wirklich
etwas verändern
aber wenn dann sozusagen die realität
publik trinken ins theater geht ändert
sich wenig was wäre da der auftrag ja
dass das ist die frage
also ich meine das beginnt ja erst mal
mit sachen im kopf ich finde tatsächlich
etwas schwach ist eine fast modellhaft
gelungene inszenierung was das angeht
dass menschen verschiedenster
politischer lager da gemeinsam ein abend
erlebt haben und das aus sehr
unterschiedlichen gründen mochten es gab
dann doch so ganz radikal libertäre die
konnten damit natürlich nichts anfangen
aber ja so der neoliberalen
auch so wirtschaftsliberale fühlten sich
immerhin mal ernst genommen von uns weil
wir eine autorin thematisieren die für
sie wichtig ist und dabei wir
unternehmer thematisieren und deren nöte
er und deren position mal überhaupt ins
zentrum rücken
und das mit dem ans bein pinkeln sagen
sie jetzt das passiert wahrscheinlich
dann von selber wenn man ein land ganz
genau liest dann kommt man da nicht
umhin das vielleicht auch nicht ganz
ernst nehmen zu können das ist sicher an
dem abend passiert und dann entstehen
auf einmal wie sie sagen debatten und
diskussionen an einer stelle wo solche
normalerweise ziemlich unwahrscheinlich
sind
es gibt es gibt es ja dass jemand wie
wenig auf eine nzz und ich uns über zwei
seiten unterhalten und tatsächlich auf
einmal was zu sagen haben das würde
normalerweise nicht passieren wir gar
nicht miteinander reden weil wir sagen
politischer gegner und dann fängt man
gleich an zu diffamieren
das ist ja schon mal anfangen und wenn
es jetzt um es gibt ja auch der vom die
konkret auf das aktionistische abzielen
zum beispiel von milo rau oder der auch
bei uns ja was macht die wahrscheinlich
viel konkreter in so eine richtung gehen
die sie jetzt fordern hat denn das jetzt
unmittelbar eine zu messen bewirken
ich wollte ja gar nicht fordern ich habe
ja nur die frage gestellt vom markt
theater das heute überhaupt noch um die
frage stellt sich auch deswegen weil die
frage ja auch ist und wir eigentlich aus
gesellschaft noch genug gemeinsames
haben auf das sie uns beziehen können
das ist ja auch so eine schwierigkeit
dass man sagt ja einerseits kultur soll
verbinden das steht auch in der kultur
botschaft des bundesrates aus ein
wichtiges ziel gemeinschaft stärken und
zugleich kann man ja irgendwie auch nur
gemeinschaft stärken wenn man überhaupt
irgendwo anfangen kann also ein
einfaches beispiel der morgenstraich ist
ja abgesagt worden wegen corona ist
natürlich endor verbindend gemeinschaft
stiften kann aber auch nur gemeinschaft
stiften sein weil die leute dieses
brauchtum kennen weil natürlich wissen
was der morgenstraich ist weil die
wissen wie diese ganzen verschiedenen
märsche und so weiter funktionieren
und da hätte ich die frage haben wird
das noch dieses gemeinsame was im
theater auf bilden können
was zunächst mal ich möchte auch noch
jetzt ein schritt zurück und kommen dann
aber zum zusammenhalt aber zunächst mal
sagen theater vermag nicht nur politisch
zu sein sondern es ist politisch oder es
ist es ist eben in den formen genau das
was sie gesagt haben es führt etwas vor
in einem raum des als ob und das gibt
uns spielmöglichkeiten oder wir können
diese kurse zeigen wir sind noch nicht
drehen wir sind nicht im politischen
wettstreit müssen sofort wer hat recht
und auch in einer wissenschaft sondern
ist es gibt dass es gibt die
gleichzeitigkeit der widersprüche es
gibt die verschiedenheiten oder man holt
eben jemanden auch durch einen text der
ein etwas anderes vermuten lassen dann
spürt man doch eine kritik also ich
glaube da ist auch einfach viel offen
manchmal passiert aber auch nicht das
ist das recht der kunst das manchmal
auch nichts passiert und jetzt sonst
sind wir immer viel zu ökonomisch am
nutzen der kunst rang nein sie einfach
einen freiraum und dann passieren solche
dinge ereignen sich dinge die sind
wichtig und ja auch manchmal werden
gemeinschaften gestiftet es ist auf
jeden fall ein gemeinschaftserlebnis in
einem theater aber manchmal gehen leute
auch raus und das ist gut dann passiert
auch aus also ich finde kunst und kultur
verbindet sie findet nicht im luftleeren
raum statt greift immer auf etwas zurück
was auch gemeinsam ist verständlich ist
sonst hat sie keinen widerhall glaube
ich sie muss etwas gemeinsames aufnehmen
aber manchmal trennt sie auch sie löst
zusammenhänge auch sie bricht sie
unterbricht und das ist ihnen also ich
bin nicht nur sagen es stiftet
zusammenhalt sondern ein beides ist
nicht auf es verbindet es verknüpft neu
es öffnet einen raum des als ob und
darin ist so viel mehr möglich und das
ist wichtig wenn wir uns fragen wie
wollen wir gut und gerecht zusammenleben
diese frage ist unpolitisch und das
lautet natürlich genau diese fragen nach
der gemeinsamen basis ja aus sondern das
war vor 50 jahren bestimmt einfacher da
gab einen kleinen kanon da gab es
irgendwie eine weiße mittel und
oberschicht die war sehr homogen
jetzt leben wir in einer sehr viel
breiteren heterogenen welt und an der
front kämpfen wir im theater und wie ich
glaube oft auch sehr erfolgreicher indem
man sagt wir nehmen so was wie faust das
ist gar nicht mehr für alle leute kann
und da haben bestimmte menschen mal
irgendwas von gehört zwar kaum jemand
mehr gelesen und überführen das in ein
erlebnis wo die menschen auf einmal mit
ist etwas erleben von dem sie nicht
dachten dass wir das mit diesem
komischen alten kram erleben können und
umgekehrt dass die menschen sein das ist
unser kader noch im bett kriegen ach das
steht da drin
aha und da darüber bringt man
tatsächlich doch auch wieder sehr sehr
unterschiedliche lebenswelten und genau
zusammen aber damit müssen ja
tatsächlich auch immer ringen stelle ich
mir vor also gerade das thema
passionsspiele
man kann diese diese anspielung
sozusagen auf eine form der kultur die
sich ab arbeitet am leiden eben
ursprünglich leiden jesus am karfreitag
gar nicht verstehen wenn man nicht weiß
was ein passionsspiel ist also wie
können sie überhaupt das publikum
ansprechen wenn das was sie kann um
genannt haben
vielleicht ja tatsächlich bröckelt ja
ich finde genau die frage super
interessant und ich arbeite unglaublich
gerne dran ab und fand das sehr sehr
produktiv was da entsteht und genau
diese fragen stellt weil ich glaube auch
dass das nicht ganz stimmt also auch
ohne dass man weiß was passionsspiele
sind kann man diese lieder und diese
clips sehen und erkennen und kann sie in
weißwasser ist der humor da drin und so
weiter das ist ja so eine überschrift
die schreibt man mal hin wissen dass es
eine referenz gibt um zu gucken was mit
diesen referenzen passiert in
verschiedenste richtungen und konkret
kam dass hier jetzt von der von der
erinnerung daran dass diese
passionsspiele als form der
spätmittelalterlichen oder ausgehende
ausgehen der renaissance auch teilweise
immer was mit solchen zu oder oft was
mit solchen zu tun hatten oberammergauer
passionsspiele das war während einer
pest epidemie ist das entstanden
und jetzt in den ersten ja auch immer
noch gibt es immer noch ich jetzt erst
mal einer der wenigen male verschoben
worden wegen der nächsten ist auch
interessant warum hätte ich nicht mehr
aber in den ersten wochen des lok downs
habe ich das auf einmal so verstanden
warum die menschen aus oberammergau
nach einer zeit der quarantäne und der
isolation wegen einer epidemie sich
spüren wenn das vorbei ist dann werden
wir theater machen ja nicht gesagt wird
gehen unsere holzwerkstätten und machen
weiter holz jesus figur sondern wir
machen eine kunstform die gemeinsam ist
die mit kontakt zu tun hat wir wollen
wieder gemeinsam erleben das ganze dorf
soll kommen und das besiegt dann die
epidemie und ich verstehe wie sich eben
arbeiten an dem was wir kaum genannt
habe
ich würde trotzdem gerne nochmal weiter
drehen und semmering ins spiel bringen
ein professor aus melbourne
der hat die these vertreten dass er
gesagt hat die säkularisierung die rollt
gerade in einer zweiten welle über die
westliche welt hinweg die erste welle
hat wenn man zum beispiel an charles
taylor erinnert gesagt religion wird zur
option religion ist nicht mehr
selbstverständlich religion ist eine
option unter anderen um die zweite welle
sagt nun seinen julia erfasst eben nun
auch die geisteswissenschaften die
kulturwissenschaften eben auch theater
kunst und so weiter das alles wird zur
option also anders gesagt es gehört
nicht mehr zwingend dazu dass man mozart
kennt bach kennt wenn man sich
kultiviert nennen will sondern kultur
ist optional
und da wird es doch schwierig dieses
verbinden der wirklich noch herzustellen
ja also ob das stimmt weiß ich noch mal
zuerst nicht aber wenn sie stimmt dann
könnte man auch sagen es hat auch
einfach eine pluralisierung zur folge
und eine noch einmal eine eine
steigerung eigentlich eines
freiheitlichen anspruchs was ich
zunächst mal gar nicht trauen würde und
deshalb finde ich auch bei kunst also es
ist ja immer so da würde ich ihnen
völlig recht geben die einen holtmann
aktivisten noch wird durch das
passionsspiel die vermissten dann
vielleicht dass das volume es darum
gehen und wir haben keine ahnung aber
oder haben nur so eine spannung von
diesem begriff und ich war jetzt mal zu
sagen gute kunst oder zumindest
spannende interessante konstrukt
menschen immer auf ganz
unterschiedlichen ebenen ab nicht nur
auf einer linie an sondern es werden
viele sinne angesprochen es werden viele
wissensinhalte angesprochenen man volt
menschen unterschiedlich ab und man holt
sie eben in der gruppe auf ob man
spricht eben manchmal auch den einzelnen
mit einem duo dann passiert was
und dann passiert was für diesen
einzelnen und aber natürlich auch wieder
für die ganze konstellation die ich
empfinde mischer denkt eine gesellschaft
auch wenn ich mir alle wissen was eine
passion ist oder an pfingsten in den
gottesdienst gehen gibt es natürlich
trotzdem wissensbestände die da sind und
kulturelle gemein
kiten auf die man zurückgreifen kann ist
aber gering und auch unterbricht jemand
pflegt sie auch indem man sie
dekonstruiert würde ich jetzt mal sagt
sie nicht nur indem man sie linear
bestätigt sondern das ist ja auch das
ist ein diskurs mit passion und ja also
im theater aber es ist auch ein
religionswissenschaftliche theoretischer
vielleicht das ist auch an eine
auseinandersetzung eines glauben denn
das ist alles gar nicht so klar und das
ist das gut so ich würde ihnen gerne
folgen aber sie sind mir ein bisschen zu
wie soll ich sagen zu optimistisch also
ich hab manchmal schon diese angst dass
ein gewisser grundbestand sonst
zerbröckelt also wenn sagen wir jetzt
mal kinder die geschichte von noah zum
beispiel nicht mehr mit kriegen nur der
die ache baut dann werden sie in one ins
kunsthaus spazieren und gewisse
kunstwerke nicht dekorieren können wenn
wir mal so technisch sprechen wollen sie
steht in den kopf schüttelt den kopf ich
also für mich ist diese realisierung das
ist genau das fällt auf dem ich arbeite
einerseits sicher auch aus einem großen
interesse an diesem kanon an einem
transport dieses kann und andererseits
aber auch anna interesse was tritt an
die stelle also für mich ist das nicht
so ein großer skandal der da gerade
passiert sondern ich glaube man kann das
durchaus als bereicherung ziehen also
ich würde dem optimismus bleiben und
denke dann mit dieser anlass besteht für
den unkundigen museumsbesucher sich
diese fragen zu stellen ist es wiederum
wichtig dass es das museum gibt und
genau so ist es auch mit dem theater
also es ist wichtig dass diese
institution halten dass die vital
bleiben dass die auch diesen schritt
mitgehen und den sprung mit gehen und
nicht sagen nein wir wollen nur unseren
kann und unser altes publikum und das
bröckelt alles ist wird so zerstört und
wir hören jetzt also nur noch gebraucht
oder so sondern dass man sagt nein genau
das sind überhaupt keine widersprüche
sondern das ist genau das reiche
kulturelle panorama was sich uns bietet
und für mich ist es in meiner konkreten
arbeit immer super material also alle
diese häuser museen theater bibliotheken
sind eine art vielleicht holen um
reflexion räume zu bieten auch unsere
geschichte zum beispiel zu reflektieren
ich würde ihnen gerne auch noch nicht
die kritische frage sondern die
gartenzwerg frage stellen die ich vorhin
schon den soziologe dirk baecker
gestellt habe nämlich
ausgehend von einem lied von element of
crime eine berliner band die diese
schöne zeile hat ohne sprache wäre der
mensch ein gartenzwerg zu fragen was
wäre der mensch nicht nur ohne sprache
sondern auch ohne kultur wenn sprache
ist ja auch kultur und für mich stimmt
diese analyse irgendwie ohne kultur
während der gartenzwerge wir wären
verstärkt wir wären nicht das was uns
als menschen wie auch ausmacht nämlich
eben zu reflektieren uns mit unserer
geschichte unserer herkunft und so
weiter auseinander zu setzen
folgen sie mir oder was wir die fehlen
ohne kultur also ich ein bisschen
gefährlich dass man in solchen debatten
in kulturbegriff sehr weit fassen und
dann redet man über alles möglich also
auch eine atombomben kulturelles eine
errungenschaft gewissem oder die
müllabfuhr oder so und wir reden ja
jetzt er so von kultur im sinne von
kunst und kultur oder so auch was was
ich triebunterdrückung die zurichtung zu
fabrikarbeit das sind alles kulturelle
errungenschaften die nicht nur gut sind
die auch in der philosophie nicht noch
positiv wahrgenommen und rezipiert
werden und ich glaube wenn wir jetzt
kultur sagen ist es doch ein bisschen
und wie die die frage was braucht der
mensch um dieses diese art von leben
führen zu können also was geht über die
drei zivilisatorische errungenschaft
dass wir hier im trockenen sitzen und so
weiter über das technische hinaus also
was macht ihn wieder zu menschen was was
schiller dann fragen sagen würde würde
das ist eben das spiel oder so und da
denkt man ja so ein gartenzwerg es in
der fast schon wieder einerseits eine
kulturelle errungenschaft und es ist ja
wiederum ein produkt der fantasie und
vielleicht dann auch eine möglichkeit
des menschen der kultiviert in der natur
lebt irgendwie mit dieser natur
umzugehen oder das ist schon noch eine
ganz andere sublimation leistung die uns
zum gartenzwerg wiederum setzt und weil
man ist uns schnell dabei dass man sagte
naturzustand ist ja nicht nur schlecht
und ist auch in der philosophie nicht
nur schlecht angesehen und nicht
ich muss sie auch schmunzeln als der
garten und wer kommt denn der
gartenzwerg ist natürlich wieder riese
oder wie viele diese dieser figuren
unserer vorstellungswelt entsprungen
conti märchen vor es ist ein kulturgut
vielleicht auch und ich würde noch mal
sorgen ein mensch ohne kultur ist schon
ist schon etwas elementaren beraubt weil
kultur eben zum menschsein dazu gehört
das ist ein elementarer teil von
menschen oder nicht ich würde nicht
sagen kultur macht menschen menschlich
sondern umgekehrt der mensch ist ein
kulturelles wesen er erschafft so baut
er die möglichkeit hat irgendwelche
formen von kultur also kultur in einen
viel weiteren sinn jetzt aufgefasst aus
schon diese kanonisierte kunst sondern
einfach pflege gestaltung der welt wir
sind gestalten gewesen und wir wünschen
uns irgendwie gestaltend einfluss nehmen
zu können und ja ich würde er vielleicht
so ein vertrockneter paarung oder
irgendwo nichts mehr wächst wo nichts
mehr entfaltet wird das wäre für mich
sein und wüste wird gerne einen schritt
weiter gehen mit ihnen noch über dieses
publikum sprechen und über die frage
geben wie habe jetzt kultur reagiert in
dieser krise während des lockouts und
wie hängen zb eben auch digitalisierung
und kultur zur zeit ein zusammen
und in diesem zusammenhang ist mir helge
schneider aufgefallen viele häuser haben
ja während des lok bauen ihre
aufführungen des streams die haben
aufführung teil kerl ins netz gestellt
und helge schneider hat sich auf
facebook an seine fans angewendet und
hat gesagt ich bin ein auftrete
auftreten kann ich zurzeit nicht und
deswegen mache ich nichts davon im
moment in der nächsten zeit in der
nächsten zeit wird ist für mich nicht
möglich sein aufzutreten
ich muss alles schon mal klar stellen
ich trete nicht auch vor autos ich trete
nicht auf von menschen die anderthalb
meter auseinander setzen
und mund nasen schutz tragen ich trete
auch nicht auf im internet in einem
streamen gestreamten programm in eine
streaming dingsda roomster
ich hab da so keine ahnung von ich weiß
gar nicht wie man da so reinkommt
ich kann nur eins sagen ich will mich
damit auch nicht anfahren
denn beim streamen
da fehlt ja ein ganz ganz wichtiger teil
für meine arbeit
da seid ihr ja ganz klar das
funktioniert da nicht damit ist also
meine arbeit schon mal erst mal für die
nächste längere zeit in frage gestellt
ich komme auch nicht klar
meine idee ist erst wieder aufzutreten
wenn alle freiheiten wieder da sind also
wirklich alles ansonsten das nicht
versteht man ansonsten geht das nicht
ohne publikum das format von dem her
geschneidert sprich geht wahrscheinlich
ansonsten wirklich nicht also einen
komiker oder ein musik komiker der helge
schneider ist er diesen direkten
zuspruch braucht des publikums das auch
untereinander kontakt hat das geht
sicher nicht unter den bedingungen sehen
wir entgegen sie ihn wahrscheinlich auch
noch eine ganze zeit da hat er recht
das video geht ja glaube ich weiter und
er sagt ich werde bücher schreiben ich
wertsachen helge schneider ist übrigens
auch jemand der super solche videos ins
netz stellt immer so drei minuten clip
das beherrscht der sehr gut er wird
weiter künstlerisch tätig sein so wie
ich auch in den letzten wochen
künstlerisch tätig war ich hab ganz viel
geschrieben ich habe wieder
also man braucht für bestimmte künstler
produktivität nicht unbedingt das
theater mit dem direkten publikum aber
für andere sachen schon und da ist das
da sind wir jetzt gerade sehr gefordert
im theater zu gucken welche formate
gehenden oder welche formate müssen wir
entwickeln die unter den bedingungen
gehen können aber trotzdem ist es ja so
dass auch wenn ein theater gestreamt
wird sind die meinungen geteilt und es
gibt viele die sagen es ist wirklich
nicht das gleiche auch wenn das jetzt
nicht helge schneider ist und nicht ein
schauspieler der mit dem publikum
interagiert
ist die stimmung einfach anders wenn ich
das zu hause vor dem bildschirm gucken
außerdem würde ich schon etwas
abgewinnen können und ich glaube auch
alle die kunst schaffen haben ja ein
ganz besonderes gespür für medien für
materialien und wählen dann eben auch
ihr medium es ist etwas anderes ob ich
filmemacherin werse oder ein buch
schreibe oder aufs theater gehe oder
eben eine installation mache oder ein
marmor stein behauen
das sind ja ganz andere materialien man
wählt eben den stoff als ausdrucksmittel
für für sich und für das was man
vielleicht auch ausdrücken will
und wenn man kunst hatte ja nie
berührungsängste mit dem digitalen schon
überhaupt nichts gibt ganz spannende
digitale projekte
es ist für mich schon ein großer
unterschied ob ein künstler mit dem
digitalen arbeitet weil er sich hoch
spannendes medium oder ob es sozusagen
jemand ist der fürs theater arbeitet mit
dem publikum in einem raum und dann wird
das einfach gefilmt und sozusagen
reduziert auf diese perspektive einer
kamera dann ist nämlich ein wirklich
neues medium mit dem spiel
und dann muss man wieder anfangen dann
gibt es wieder neue möglichkeiten usw
aber zunächst einmal ist es doch nicht
das was was der kunst schaffen wir oder
die kunstschaffenden zunächst gewollt
hatten und ich gehe immer noch davon aus
es vielleicht einfacher bei uns hat aber
das sozusagen jedes komma in einem text
von einem schriftsteller einer
schriftstellerin relevanz habt und und
jedes haar oder jeder jede farbe einer
einer perücke haben eine beton ist so
gewollt und das unterschiedlich jedem
kunstwerk seine absolute gewandtheit und
dann ist es eben schon das ist nicht und
dann ist es irgendwie ein gewisser so
lasst uns einfach gemacht ist dass man
jetzt gezwungen ja gewarnt oder dass man
dann jetzt eine oper sozusagen streamt
anschaut das hat auch qualität ich kann
es genießen und so weiter aber es ist
nicht dasselbe drei das publikum fehlt
nicht nur aber auch natürlich das ist
sicher etwas ganz wichtiges das
verstehen auch hier sofort also das
lachen die reaktion man hört die leute
wussten man merkte das ist ja schon auch
passieren sondern spart ja ich finde
eben interessant es fehlt auch die
kontrolle und das ist ja lustig weise
gesagt haben freiheit also theater ist
der freiheit
aber ich finde wenn man ins theater geht
oder in die oper geht dann kontrolliert
man sich ja auch gegenseitig kann zum
beispiel nicht mittendrin meine mails
checken oder bügeln oder aufs klo gehen
sondern man sitzt da irgendwie fest das
stört ja sogar was husten überraschend
auspackt aber diese form der des
konzentriert sein müssen hat irgendwie
was ich meine das ist ja auch mittel um
eben intensität auch zu kreieren oder
also das licht geht aus dem vorhang geht
auf das sind ja alles diese räumungen
gehört natürlich auch zur inszenierung
dessen jetzt beginnt unter den
spannungsaufbau man muss auch
unterhalten werden intensiv gefesselt
werden das ist natürlich elemente von
chronisten haben sie sicher recht da ich
denke auch also in so gesehen waren
jetzt diese letzten wochen ein ganz
interessantes experiment nämlich was
fehlt uns wenn das wegfällt und man darf
aber nicht vergessen also alles was
passiert ist was man da im internet
gemacht war ja nicht nur weil wir
unbedingt jetzt nicht mehr vor leuten
spielen wollten sondern weil es nicht
anders ging und die alternative wäre
immer gewesen gar nichts zu machen und
wir haben uns die ganze zeit mühe
gegeben und tun das jetzt auch im
hinblick auf die nächste saison
dass man da mehr hat als einfach nur
eine reduktion also wenn sich das so an
viel wie für helge schneider
ich mach da was und das ist da nur halb
so gut dann wäre ich auch dafür dass zu
lassen und da konsequenz zusätzlichen
arbeiten wir sehr daran was können wir
unter den gegebenen bedingungen machen
was kann man machen gar keine zuschauer
was kann man an den bedingungen machen
nur ein schauspieler das war christopher
reeve war nur monologe
was können wir machen jetzt unter den
bedingungen die im moment herrscht es
wird schon geprobt es können nur
bestimmte anzahl von menschen in einem
raum sein die müssen einen abstand haben
das heißt ja was für eine kunstform
da finde ich das wichtig dass wir in die
ja so dahin kommen dass das zu einer
künstlerischen entscheidung das ist
nicht nur eine reduzierung das ist auch
das was immerhin oder eine künstlerische
entscheidung heißt auch die
digitalisierung nicht einfach auf mittel
zum zweck gegen wie zu nutzen sondern an
sich einzubauen oder zum thema zu machen
ja es gibt ja unendlich viele spannende
möglichkeiten mitte mit dem die gitarren
und das wird ja auch längst gemacht von
corona das ist nichts neues für kunst
ist er sogar in eine vorreiterin viele
künstler künstlerinnen haben
experimentiert und neue dinge
ausprobiert mit verschiedenen
technologien
da gibt es keine berührungsangst aber es
ist ein entscheidender entscheidung
dahinter und jetzt ist ja interessant
diese erfahrung was fehlt und was fehlt
den menschen wenn sie zu hause und das
sind ja immer auch so ähnliche wege in
der nzz am sonntag solche solche
populistischen attacken die davor immer
gesagt haben ja was theater eigentlich
mal gemacht hat das macht jetzt netflix
was braucht ihr euch überhaupt die haben
viel mehr geld die kann die clevereren
erzielen möglichkeiten die wir irgendwie
teureren produktionsbedingungen und
jetzt sieht man aber nach wie lange war
es jetzt acht wochen oder neun wochen
netflix was da fehlt ja das ist sein man
hat alles man hat das spiel man hat auch
die tragödie man hat irgendwie auch
modellhaft konflikte diese ganzen sagt
was man nicht hat ist das
gemeinschaftserlebnis mit allen vor und
nachteilen ich bin leider auch oft im
theater weil ich nicht auf einmal raus
gehen kann oder weil ich mich
eingezwängt fühlen und so weiter
versuche ich dann inszenierung
aufzugreifen dass man zwischendurch auch
die leute mal wieder ein bisschen
auflockert auch das geht aber dieses
gemeinschaftserlebnis fällt weg und da
fällt auf einmal enorm viel und alle
vermissen das und da merke ich das auf
eine art an dass doch wieder ein beweis
ist dass diese kunstform den vielen
manchmal so als bisschen veraltet gilt
oder so eine große relevanz gerade jetzt
vielleicht zum schluss sie haben in
einer kolumne deine corona chronik die
sie schreiben für die nzz haben sie
geschrieben sie hätten eine idee für
einen werbespot weil die friseursalons
durften ja schon wieder öffnen dann
haben sie gesagt theater friseure der
seele schreibt ich hätte in vorschlag
für sie sie könnten doch noch dafür mit
philosophie tattoo für den geist
betrachten seite kann man solche
aufgaben ja das war natürlich aber auch
durchaus ein ironischer seitenhieb auch
so bestimmte art von selbstmarketing
dies oft gibt eine theater muss sein und
so weiter wo man fragen kann naja ich
glaube dass entstehen musste sein muss
also friseure der seele
ganz herzlichen dank dass sie hier zu
gast waren
danke schön ja worin der wert der kultur
besteht das hat diese woche auch die
radiosendung kontext diskutiert unter
anderem mit harald welzer
und übermorgen dienstag blicken sie
nochmals zurück auf die zeit des
schattens nachzuhören auf der website
der sendung ja und war schon feiert der
jahrhundert philosoph hegel seinen 250
geburtstag ich post auch nächste woche
mit der hegel experten die neben uns in
seine denkwelten jetzt gleich gehts zur
musikerinnen und musiker die die großen
stimmen der schweiz als bandmitglieder
oder background sänger begleiten und
sonst nicht im rampenlicht stehen zeigt
ihnen einen film zu rütteln
viel vergnügen damit eine gute woche bis
bald
[Musik]